i mean i think the only scary thing for
me uh was because i'd never gotten
covered before like normally when i get
an illness i've been ill enough times to
know how my body deals with it you know
like okay i'm gonna be out for x amount
of days i need to do this like i've got
this down to a science right you know i
i you know i wake up with you know like
um
like what's what's the what's the throat
itis uh todd's license or something you
know which has happened a few times i'm
just like okay i'm gonna be calm down
for two days i'm not gonna be able to
speak for like three four days and then
afterwards i'll be completely fine right
but when i tested positive i'm just like
[ __ ] i've never i've never done this
before so this is all new territory for
me man like how's my body gonna react
with i've got asthma is that gonna play
an effect i'm just like i it it wasn't
like this i didn't have a bad time it
was more of just like the unknown that
uh
that scared me the most right
because it was something completely new
that i had never experienced before so i
had no prior knowledge about how i
should best deal with it or how my body
was going to deal with it luckily it was
fine second thing that i kind of [ __ ]
myself over was the uh everyone's saying
that you might lose your sense of taste
i'm just like you know what i i think i
think i'd rather go to hospital than
lose my sense of taste honestly what do
you mean with the bread take you surely
do i think a lot of people would argue
that you already did so you haven't gone
before pretty sure they're covered for
like the best trash taste recording yeah
half of these foods i don't think you
have any taste buds to kill
yeah you you know like the first thing
that i did when i tested positive was
obviously i needed to inform mailin to
like inform geeks plus and everything
the office that i tested positive and
the first thing she messages me about is
oh uh i've heard that uh covered might
like change your taste buds so maybe
you'll be able to taste bread now i'm
just like [ __ ] you melon
roasted
this is not what i wanted when i tested
positive okay
were you did you were you hungry at all
did you have an appetite when you
it was like exactly the same okay so
like here's the thing i hate about being
[ __ ] ill right is that it's like i i
didn't lose my sense of taste but like
it was just the same
like affect your taste that you have
with any illness which just for some
reason everything just tastes [ __ ]
everything just tastes bland man i get
super hungry when i get sick yeah i
remember like so weird that's because
remember when you got ill like the few
weeks before when you got like
tonsillitis you just ate a [ __ ] ton and
to me like i i can't eat at all when i'm
ill i just i just don't
assuming my stomach is okay and like i
have any other illness i'll just eat a
lot i don't know why i for me when i'm
sick like just the smell of food is like
one time food poisoning i got food
poisoning this one time and then the
next day while i was still dying i got
so hungry for like mcdonald's
so i ordered like a [ __ ] ton of
mcdonald's and i ate all of it yeah i
weirdly i felt a lot better i don't know
why i feel like i'm the only person on
earth who binged mcdonald's and then
felt better yeah
because usually that's the thing that
gives you food poisoning yeah that's
exactly right you think you mcdonald's
after having food
the one time i do regret doing this is
one time i was really sick again i think
with food poisoning the next day i know
everyone's gonna laugh i decided to get
indian curry
that was actually a mistake why would
you do that i was really craving like
butter curry i don't know why i
you know i i crave a lot of good food
when i'm ill as well but i'm like i
i've had it enough times that you regret
it immediately yeah you take the first
book that was the only time i've
regretted it other times i've gotten it
i feel better i don't know if it's like
in my mind i'm like yeah this maybe my
body's like oh [ __ ] we got another
problem to deal with let's deal with
that and then everything just gets
better yeah
i don't know it's it's low [ __ ] really
your brain works one step at a time
i don't know it's all it's all weird i
feel like i no one really understands
their body we're all just guessing we're
all just doing we're like we're like
we're like uh plague doctors trying to
figure out our thing with our own weird
rituals i think we all just have a thing
that we feel comfortable with and
somehow it works we've sorted it we've
done we've been ill enough times to know
kind of how our body
reacts to certain things and to deal
with certain things everyone bodies is
different yeah i'll sit there and like
laugh at all these plague doctors from
the 18th century and then i'll just be
like i'm gonna will power my disease
away and so i'm like it's only really
have we changed at all i don't think so
i think that we've just gotten smarter
wow you know i'll fix my stomach
mcdonald's
dude exactly that's what i'm saying wait
but like before covert like how often
did you guys get sick like per year once
a year no yeah
food poisoning i feel like food
poisoning to me he seems to get food
poisoning a lot food poisoning to me i
don't count us getting like sick
no that's definitely
that is illness that is illness because
it's like it's like uh if if i poisoned
god you wouldn't be like oh god god got
sick you'd be like gum it's poisoned
right it's a different kind of vibe it's
just sickness you know what i mean it's
the only thing you treat it's like
you've got food poisoning yeah you
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] just deal with it
wait do do you know what food poisoning
is yes because it's not like someone
slipped cyanide into your mouth no i
know i know but it's like it's like it's
not caused by like a natural cause of
like sickness or a bacteria or virus
it's like something went wrong no it is
it is it is it is no i know i know but
it's not like you got it by accident or
something you know what i mean like you
stumble across it it's like something
had to go wrong for it to be there no i
think it's by accident right yeah no no
no no you you wouldn't know something's
wrong with the food unless you've tried
that i know right that's what i'm saying
like i don't count that as like the
natural quota of getting sick because
like let's say you undercooked chicken
and there's salmonella in it that's just
like that's [ __ ] you're done yeah but
that's not the fault of the person who
cooked the chick under cookie chicken
that's the fault of the salmonella oh
that's where you cook the chicken which
is the disease that comes right right
yeah but that's like you would ever come
across naturally right that's not
something you would normally come across
like let's say what do you mean by come
across like just like on the street
something like carried like gan is like
carrying like a normal i don't know a
cold or whatever right it's different
category in my mind i don't know well
like not every raw piece of chicken has
salmonella no
there is a chance that if you have a raw
piece of chicken and it's not cooked
then the salmonella or the bacteria have
steps
in the same way that if you uh if you go
outside and someone has covered or the
flu or something and you stand next to
them and they cough and then you inhale
particles then you have the chance of
getting it it's right in my mind i just
put it differently
because food poisoning is normally just
due to the lack of like somebody [ __ ]
up
right you mean like lack of uh
lack of like under cooking yeah
undercooking and stuff like that or bad
bad stuff not all the time though just
sometimes they'll just be like a road or
like e coli and [ __ ] yeah that's that's
yeah that's a big [ __ ] up sometimes it's
just a matter of like oh you know there
was a piece of food there and just you
know unfortunately just a rogue you know
disease or virus just happened to
[ __ ] stumble upon oh i mean can you
inhale it it's different though right
because then we are you saying that food
poisoning is more preventable yeah way
more preventable well that's why you can
be like your restaurant can be shut down
if you keep giving people food poisoning
oh yeah it's the majority of the time
something like food poisoning is due to
somebody [ __ ] up in the in the chain
of of pro like because we have these
steps right so so basically the the most
times you get ill is uh when
someone has [ __ ] up and given you food
poisoning yeah or you [ __ ] up and
giving yourself mainly me i look at it
and i'm like ah [ __ ] it and then i eat
it
so that's so that's why you don't count
it as getting ill right because it's
kind of on you it's kind of weird
because like if you were if i just
walked past someone in the street who
was ill i don't count that in the same
thing i'm kind of kind of understanding
this mentality now it's not an illness
it's a cell phone
i don't know it's just different in my
head
no i don't know about you i can't food
poisoning as an illness i do count food
boys but then again i've gotten i don't
get sick often but i think i've only
ever gotten food poisoning maybe like
twice in my life i didn't get it much
time i came to japan i've had it many
times in japan weirdly really yeah like
four i've never gotten food poisoning in
japan yeah i've never gotten food
poisoning in japan i've got it
like the worst food poisoning i've
gotten was in china um and also
sometimes in thailand as well i think i
got really bad food poisoning in the
philippines yeah i think you know
um but i think food poisoning in
southeast asia is just like part of the
experience right yeah
and
yeah yeah yeah
street street food preventable
street food in southeast asia it is not
preventable
is everywhere
time when i went back for a while yeah
yeah
i never i never knew you could get food
poisoning from a mango but i i
definitely got it from a mango like that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up dude
i swear to god every time sydney has
oysters she gets like [ __ ] food
poisoning and every [ __ ] time she's
like maybe this time i won't maybe this
time maybe like i hear like you hear you
know every now and then there's like
there's those foods that's like yeah
food poisoning central right yeah
oysters being one of them yeah that is
poor storage i've never gotten it from
oysters it's so weird you probably only
eat eating oysters here in japan right
no no everywhere really yeah i had it in
the us australia everywhere and i've
never gotten it that's a gamble in the
uk really yeah it's very much a gambling
uk and i think a lot of places in the us
as well because it depends how well they
store it or how fresh it is human error
scene this is why it's why don't you
count the same in my head
if somebody sneezes at me in public i'm
like that can't be helped you know
whatever but if somebody if somebody
forgot to [ __ ] freeze a piece of fish
then served it to me someone [ __ ] up
and made me sick
how was someone sneezing on you not a
human error well no you like let's say
you're in a plane right someone four
seats behind you sneezes whatever they
didn't they didn't react quick enough i
feel like that's not that's they can't i
can't possibly react quickly i could i
couldn't then go to like court and be
like this person sneezed on the plane
behind me and didn't cover up their face
you know i i feel like it's not you
can't hold someone accountable whereas
like let's say somebody just didn't
store a piece of fish properly that's
like negligence on their part and then
they served it yeah i get that that's
the why i don't treat it the same but i
don't treat it the same either but it's
still an illness yeah it's it's
it's
like
it
would you count cancer as an illness
then
you don't get cancer from eating fish
what i'm saying is it's you treat it
completely differently but it's still an
illness right yeah but like that's true
you can just get right that's just like
different because that's like that that
most of the time lung cancer yeah yeah
what if like you smoke enough yeah
yeah humanity that's on you
and then in that case it wouldn't be an
illness
you know stuff like that it's like only
raises your chances right where it's
like if somebody just gives you flat out
a completely like [ __ ] up piece of
fish or meat that's been stored in
properly you're going to get sick for
100 right whereas like you there are
people who've been chained smoking from
like age 10 to 100 who don't get it
right so it's complete luck on that part
but with the with the with the storage
food and all that that's like all right
somebody [ __ ] up you know what i mean
that's categorically someone just [ __ ]
up and they gave it to you and poisoned
you that's what it is it's different to
like getting an illness it's totally
different
doctors in the comments are cracking up
right now i'm
i actually want to know what people
think about this i feel like i'm not the
only one who thinks this way towards
like food poisoning this is not a weird
thing i mean i just i it's just you
getting ill i'll just stand
like if you ask me how often do i get
ill i wouldn't count that because that's
got nothing to do with like
an illness no it's not you're literally
sick if if i were to just like make
myself vomit would you say like i've
gotten an illness no well then why would
food poisoning count towards that
because it's a literal disease well
that's got nothing no comment to like
how often you get ill that's how often
you eat bad [ __ ]
no
yeah
no that's not entirely different no i
mean it all depends on your environment
right but obviously if you know if if
you're in an environment where a lot of
you know where like a lot of people are
ill we're going through a wave of
illness then you're more likely to get
ill in the same way if you live in an
environment where people are you know
where people are less careful with their
food preparation then you're more likely
to get ill you know that's that's right
that is the thing if you go to southeast
asia or you know a lot of places where
the food standards aren't as high no
like it's true it's true it's true
i'm i'm not i'm not throwing shade i'm
just saying facts here okay guys i'm
saying faxing you know you go to a
[ __ ] street vendor on the street
you're just like how was how is this me
prepared where did this me come from
they don't [ __ ] know you think you're
from the back of my truck yeah exactly
right exactly you know um i mean
i mean it's it's all it's it's all risk
it's all risk at the end of the day you
know you can eat raw chicken in japan
you know it's still and apparently here
it's more safer because
uh because you know food standards here
in japan are higher i don't know how
true that is how not true it is but at
the same time you're still taking away
if you're the problem
with this what if your stomach's just
weak well no i mean if the restaurant
just gives me
like poorly stored sausage i think
that's their fault you know that's
that's not that's why because the one
thing i learned from when i was in uh
the philippines is that like yeah the
food standards are a lot lower than
normal but people don't get sick because
they just naturally have more of like a
resistant stomach right from living
there always yeah i'd say that's true
actually not with everything though not
with everything not with everything but
with a lot of things that visitors to
those countries would immediately get
secret oh yeah i wouldn't say of a weak
stomach i normally don't really have any
problem with like gross foods or
something that's a little off uh but i
mean there are times where i've eaten
something and then i've gotten really
sick and i was like why did i eat that
what what do you what do you count as
food poisoning then
because like okay you okay you you go
you go to like you go to a conference
give me an example like throw things at
me and i'll be like food poisoning or
not okay
you go you go to a country right you
taste something that your body has never
like tasted before it's like totally new
cuisine and your body's just like oh
that's not food poisoning i don't like
this and then you get like the [ __ ] for
like five days no that's not food for
you [ __ ] isn't the food portion yeah
yeah yeah if it comes back up that's
food poisoning
so to me it's like you need to have like
you know your body is literally you know
physically reacting in some way where it
gives you like a fever or a headache or
vomiting you know where i never get
normal i never get anything like that
from eating food but when i when i do
eat like i can normally remember what it
was that gave me it because i
i very much felt rough immediately after
eating yeah because i count food
poisoning as i am conked out yeah in bed
yeah i was ironing up yeah
i've got a fever because that is
it's literally like a bacterial
infection
i think if it makes you feel a little
queasy and it gives you the [ __ ] no
that's not that's just you do have a
weak stomach for that yeah but i think
if you're if you're throwing up you're
you have a fever yeah you you have food
poisoning that's what i would yeah but
then like i wouldn't in my mind if that
happens to me let's say i
you know you get that once a year oh
lately it's been more it's been like
[ __ ] i've only had that like a few times
in my life because i i order a lot of
food right i never cook myself so yeah
yeah i don't know i think it happens a
lot more also that's what i'm saying i
think it's you i think i actually think
it's just he's just you no it's not it's
not me
i'm not the one cooking i think you just
have a weak stuff no no no because it's
happened where it's not just been me who
gets sick from the food like other
people have gotten sick or with me right
so maybe they have weak stomachs too no
that's not
that is not a good defense your honor
why did you give people a cold like oh
it's got weak stomachs in it someone
started they don't need to get good but
you call it no no no that's not how it
works
because i i out of the last three times
i got food poisoning two times it was
sausage and i can distinctly remember
eating the sausage and being like hmm
really pink really really pink and i was
like i think it's okay i'll eat it and
then i regretted it after
so i learned that and the other bag was
the other one was from a
bag of flaming hot cheetos that was like
four months off
well well that again sounds like yeah
that's so fast so that's mine right but
when i
okay let's say i i'm an idiot and i eat
a four month old bag of flamin hot
cheetos right to me if i start throwing
up that in no way in my mind is in the
same category as like let's say i got a
i got tonsillitis or something because
this is like this is me being a [ __ ]
idiot yeah and then i immediately got
consequences for it right the only
difference is like let's say i got to a
restaurant is that i didn't cook it but
somebody's still [ __ ] up right let's
say the sausage was awful like so in my
head it's not in the same category as
getting like a an infection from just i
don't know where the [ __ ] i got it from
right because it's like somebody [ __ ]
up with the flaming hot cheetos i [ __ ]
up i'm massively [ __ ] up yeah all
right here's the thing okay so
you go to a convention all right all
right you go to a convention yeah you
party for like every like every day at
the convention you get conflu yeah right
everyone gets [ __ ] conflict yeah a
lot of people get [ __ ] yeah of course
does that does that count as the same
thing because you know like you're going
to a place where you know that you're
probably going to get infected with
something along the way because there's
a lot of people in a single area and
you're putting yourself in a position
where your immune system is going to be
weaker because you're naturally doing a
lot of [ __ ] does that count as a flow in
the illness which categories are the
future
yeah where which does con flu count as
they're getting sick like normal sick
getting normal yeah normal that's not
that's not food poisoning i feel like
food poisoning it is in its own complete
like category closer to like
self-poisoning to me
in my head
i don't know how do you understand why i
think that way or you just don't get it
at all i understand why you think that
because i understand i just don't agree
because it's not like i'm going to the
con and i'm going around licking flaws
and i'm licking you know what i mean
like i am just i i know that you're at a
higher risk because you're around a lot
of people yeah people know
sometimes you shake a hand or you're
just like oh i know
i better like sanitize it
sometimes you know man like my hand is
getting sick yeah yeah yeah and because
we're taking photos we're getting close
people
yeah i understand that that's just like
a big risk sometimes i get conflict
sometimes i don't but that's that's
again like it's like that's like me
almost squishing like six months of
interacting into one weekend so to me it
makes sense right that you would there
was a very high chance you could get a
six yeah yeah but again like it's not
the same with food poisoning because
again somebody had to [ __ ] up
in my head
i wonder if i'm like the only i can't be
the only person who sees it this way
there must be a lot of people i mean
you're the first in my head you're the
first person
how many people have you discussed this
with right this is not a normal thing to
discuss yeah it's not a normal thing to
discuss because i think in for most
people
food poisoning is an illness
there's like no question about it if you
asked me connor what's up why can't you
come troops recording there i'm not like
i've been poisoned i'd be like no i got
sick i gotta say but then in my head i i
would have this this category that i
would label it just happens to now we
have to talk about it and i'm explaining
it and i didn't realize that people
didn't see it this way so the next time
you get food poisoning and you say oh
sorry guys i'm sick i'm allowed to call
you out on that or yeah you can be like
who [ __ ] up yeah
i'll be like i'll be like did you eat
another [ __ ] bag of flavored hot
cheetos
at the restaurant this time
who's the culprit here's the thing right
if i get sick from a restaurant and you
only know me it's like oh oh connor are
you let's say you don't know like let's
say this restaurant is poisoned like a
hundred other people then you would
start being like what the [ __ ] is going
on why is this restaurant still opening
the only difference is that you already
hear my side right but obviously
normally a restaurant wouldn't be doing
that but still
i'm not crazy this is just it's it's a
perception you know we have i sound like
alex [ __ ] jones
turn the frog's getting with the water
you're just hearing one side of the
story it's like no i don't know i i
agree that food poisoning is very hard
to argue without sounding [ __ ] insane
i i agree with that food poisoning is in
the different category than let's say
the flu or tonsillitis but i would say
that there are a lot of illnesses that
exist that can exist in different
categories from the flu and food
poisoning and a lot of things but at the
end of the day to me in my mind they're
kind of they're all illnesses
or illnesses if you ask me are you sick
i'd be like yes if i had both yeah but
in my head i don't treat them the same
way like like like there are millions of
different illnesses with a million those
millions of different ways to prevent it
uh to stop yourself from getting ill or
all this kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
in mind that this is not like some kind
of hard scientific definition i put in
my head this is just like a mentality i
have towards thinking don't worry people
don't come to trash
people but there's always so many
comments being like i've got to post
some holes through conor's thoughts and
it's like well yeah because i didn't
really think that much about it anyway
he's just talking out of his arms she's
got a rough rough uh estimation
i just don't see the benefit in labeling
food poisoning as a difference
i
feel like that's more of like copium on
your end to be like
i'm not ill i'm not ill why why not just
say they're all illnesses i don't know i
because again this isn't something that
i ever discussed with people right not
something that comes out in the open
often obviously now i'm having to talk
about it for a million plus people but
that was not my intention just a soft
definition in my head towards how i
viewed the illness